- [Voiceover] In previous
videos on triangle congruence,
we talk about how side,
side, angle cannot be used
to establish triangle congruence.
What I'll do in this video
is I'll show you an exception
and the exception is when we are dealing
with right triangles, in particular,
when this angle is a right angle.
So, this is a 90 degree
angle in which case,
this first side is going
to be the hypotenuse
and the second is going to be
a leg, is going to be a leg.
And that's why you'll sometimes see this,
instead of calling it, you
know, instead of calling it SSA
for the special case of a right triangle,
you'll sometimes call this, see this
as hypotenuse leg congruence.
Let me do this in the same
colors so I'm consistent.
So, hypotenuse,
hypotenuse leg congruence.
And if you're dealing,
if someone saying there's a
hypotenuse of that triangle,
then that triangle by definition is going
to be a right triangle.
You can only have a hypotenuse
in a right triangle.
And to get an intuition for
why two triangles are going
to be congruent if their hypotenuse,
if each of their hypotenuses
have the same length.
Is it hypoteni, hypotenuses?
If they have the same length,
and then the leg has the same length,
we can look at these two right over here.
So, we're going to assume
that this hypotenuse,
that this hypotenuse has the same length
as that hypotenuse.
We'll say they're both of length c.
We can assume that this leg here
has the same length.
This leg here has the
same length as that leg.
We could call that length a,
and you can see that the only
way to draw the next side.
Remember, there's two
constraints now here.
We have to connect to
this point right over here
as we're dealing with the triangle.
So, we're only going to have three sides,
and it's a right
triangle, so it has to be,
the next side I draw
has to be perpendicular.
So, the only way to draw that,
the only way to draw
that is just like that.
And to feel good that, I
guess more analytically,
that this side, this green
side is congruent to this side,
we can just use the Pythagorean theorem.
The Pythagorean theorem would tell us
that this green side,
right over here, is going
to be the square root
of the hypotenuse-squared, c-squared.
c-squared minus a-squared,
minus the square
of the other leg, and
this one is also going
to be the square root of c-squared.
Actually, I'm just gonna draw an arrow.
This is gonna be true for that
and it's going to be true from that.
That comes straight out of
the Pythagorean theorem.
So, from that, we know that the third leg
or the third side, that they,
those two corresponding
sides have to be congruent.
And so, that's where we get
the hypotenuse leg congruence from,
which is really just
a special case of SSA,
which we've said in the past,
you cannot apply generally
to establish triangle congruence.